bonjour avec le printemps je me suis dit
qu'un petit voyage nous ferait du bien
aujourd'hui direction la scandinavie et
il ya deux figures incontournables en
scandinavie ce sont les trolls et les
sagas le premier livre dont je vais vous
parler justement nous emmène à la
rencontre d'un maudit troll c'est un
livre de salies greenlay et peter
automne dans la collection pastel de
l'école des loisirs
et pour une fois ce ne sont pas des
enfants qui craignent les trolls ou qui
doivent les affronter mais des animaux
en l'occurrence des boucs qui veulent
absolument traverser une rivière et qui
pour cela vous utiliser tous les moyens
vous voyez gonfler des ballons utilisés
des perches comme ici c'est un livre
dont l'histoire est assez simple au
départ mais les procédés utilisés pour
le rendre intéressant sont nombreux
alors d'abord il y a les flip flap les
enfants doivent retrouver le treuil
cachés dessous il y a également ce trio
formé par les trois boucs et puis ces
petites souris caché dans l'image qui
commente les actions comme le choeur
antique où les petites souris qui
étaient également présentes dans le film
babe et du coup ça donne une histoire à
plusieurs voix autant vous dire que ce
livre destiné aux enfants à partir de 5
ans leur plaît énormément et la fera
découvrir les trolls s'ils ne les
connaissent pas déjà
voilà c'est un très joli livre amusant
de la collection un pastel qui fête
cette année ses 30 ans puisque nous
sommes en scandinavie je voulais vous
parler d'un autre livre
ce livre là la saga de ghrib de jérémie
moreau publié aux éditions delcourt
mirage alors ce livre suit l'histoire
d'un petit orphelin grillon dans les
années 1760 en islande
à ce moment là lille est ravagée par la
famille les temps sont très dures et
elles mêmes occupée par les danois alors
le petit garçon grippe se retrouvent
ballotté
entre des êtres plus ou moins
recommandables
il se trouve qu'il est doté d'une force
surhumaine
mais il a du mal à la maîtriser car son
tempérament est plutôt impétueux les
aquarelles de jérémie moreau vous voyez
sont magnifiques et elles rendent bien
à la fois les paysages de l'atlantique
nord et ce caractère très volcanique une
petite grille mais aussi volcanique que
sont ils alors il va lui arriver tout un
tas davanture tout trépidante mais il va
finir par être rejeté de tous je ne vous
raconte pas la fin de l'histoire mais
vous verrez qu il est également question
de troll en islande
ce livre a été vraiment très très
apprécié des libraires des critiques et
de tous les lecteurs
il a même reçu le fauve d'or au festival
d'angoulême je vous le conseille donc à
partir du collège
celui ci est à partir de 5 ans elle
permettra de fêter le trentième
anniversaire de pastel et celui ci
plutôt à partir d'une dizaine d'années